okay so here we are eating your feed
where I've been challenged by Adam the
person behind the camera to mate and
pulled the noodles something I've never
made before in the offseason I said and
hey Adam
wouldn't be cool and make these noodles
completely forgot about it then he
brought it back on me and I was like
that looks so hard I regret ever saying
handful noodles
we're going to do this one made by this
guy Peter song from kung-fu kitchen in
New York City it's kind of like spinning
together like if you ever have we're on
a swing set as a kid and like wrapped it
up then you sit on it and spin around a
lot until you get close to throwing up
once it's been kneaded he's just like
watch the noodle is pulled and then
doubled over and pulled again until he
has noodle sized noodles this is like
the closest that cooking gets to magic
for me it's a very simple dough it looks
like flour water he's using a bread
flour with a higher gluten content I
think that's gonna be important to talk
through my game plan
I have chef extraordinary a that a good
setup Adam hey hey REE a is a tasty
producer always helps us when we're
messing up with stuff so today I'm doing
the hand-pulled noodles what do you
think about that you don't need to must
I write you that's true too
you just have to little bit happen I
just need some noodles in a bowl by the
end of tomorrow mm-hmm okay I'll let you
know if I need any help
bye hi okay so I did some measuring and
I've got 900 grams of flour
aka approximately 2 pounds I measured it
that way then Adam made me convert
science 20 grams of salt 450 grams of
water we begin now
[Music]
I'm gonna make a well this reminds me of
my cat because his name is Wellington
it's currently trying his hardest not to
look as doesn't seem like it's gonna be
enough water to be honest I mean I guess
when you think about it the flower is
like much is white dust but it started
out as hundreds of acres of plants and I
feel like I need more water I know what
you're feeling right now which is when
you see someone struggling with
something
it's like watching somebody open a jar
that's what this whole show is I think
it's time to let this rest so this dough
already feels a lot smoother do I need
to some flour on this surface
do I need flour on this surface
I shouldn't have added that flour
everything I'm reading says that you're
having a hard time with the elasticity
of the dough it just needs to rest
longer you don't really see it in the
reference video when they do the cut and
it comes back with this shiny log of
dough it's because of the oil okay I
think I'm gonna try the old snake test
on this thing
what am i doing I think this slapping is
because the dough is it just wants to
return to its original shape oh I broke
it instead of giving up on this dough I
think I'm just going to add water to it
why did you let me do this this is a bad
idea
wretched it again am-scray yeah so
mistakes were made we found a very
useful Cook's Illustrated article and it
turns out I did pretty much every ratio
incorrectly it also seems to be that
working with exclusively bread flour
you'll get the best result but it will
be harder to work with I feel good this
is like the stuff I should have done
before the first time so we have 900
grams flour 7 grams salt 540 grams of
water for me a little well that one I
did good come back your water okay water
what are you doing why are you thinking
when you're kneading I think
doing this right I feel like maybe you
should wash your hands okay with like
your hands are like crust crust fur
cross crusty rusty oh yeah you're so
much better at this what's very smoother
now I think it was we needed more water
okay I think it's time to let that rest
so I'm gonna put that in there so we've
made four batches of dough with
different combinations of flour salt
after it's had a really long time to
rest it should be really good to go
tomorrow
it's business time so yesterday we
prepared at four batches of dough we're
gonna go with the first one I made it's
quite cold I hope that doesn't screw me
over
oh okay it's not uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
this feels like ABC gum guys no that one
already been chewed I'm getting a couple
nods from around the room it looks like
a little slug mm mm um I think I need to
let it rest laurier hi thought you
coffee for everyone this was actually
completely on you just leaving your like
it it's really good yeah okay we've let
this go vlog rest I'm gonna gently
stretch this out or I'm gonna double it
over and see how this goes
it's gotten so tight I can't make a new
over on this it just wants to break it
reaches a tearing point pretty easily so
this one's exactly the same as the last
one but with a different salt if you do
that much stretching then it's like
we're really just burning through our
deck here though ap and bread flour
mixture it's now genuinely at room temp
and look at this well it's pretty good
let me portion off a little bit and see
how far I can get with this come over
here and try this dough fight
Oh
[Music]
oh you're out it's the new thing you
know how chokers came back into style
this is a doaker this feels like Britney
Spears what was the video toxic yep no
it just doesn't have the elasticity that
I think is required for this kind of
noodle we are in California one of the
driest periods we've ever had here all
of our recipes suggest that if it's
drier you're gonna need more water how
much more water I don't know I'm gonna
do 400 grams of water we just got to get
to a point where we're making Neuticles
says I thought my kneading days were
behind me at what point do I determine
that this is entirely too wet can I just
pull this into noodles right now I think
I need to add a little bit more flour to
this come on
a little more I need more flour I called
both on everybody's recipe that ever
published a thing about noodles he was
trying to keep the noodles for
themselves
I get it I would do it too I'm gonna
burn this tape when I successfully make
noodles
[Music]
okay having seen how these videos get
made I want to say Q the heroic music
now okay okay okay okay I'm gonna cut
off a little section like this okay and
then I'm going to fold this back up oh I
worked so hard meeting that well I
reached the tearing point okay let's try
another recipe okay
we found this recipe utilizing a stand
mixer from this guy chef Thomas Johnson
let's just follow his recipe exactly see
if it works
cake flour all-purpose flour salt and
baking soda whoo
okay boil water let's whack it up going
to speed for this is brown that will we
yeah yeah that's completely the wrong
kind of flour
maybe if I added more water to this I
wouldn't work exactly too much water
so this was a failed attempt yeah that's
a wrap on day two this is gonna require
some further research so far for this
video we've been referencing recipes
that utilize high-gluten flour to
achieve a very pulley dough I found this
guy is website Luke rye Mars there's
like nothing on it but this recipe but
he said use low-gluten flour and an
alkaline solution to help make a
suitably stretchy dough so I have
approximately 150 grams of cake flour
going into 25 grams of all-purpose flour
2 grams of salt and 1 gram of baking
soda huh
Oh to the wrong this are eight and 110
grams of water turn it into a squishy
paste
whereas we in the industry like to call
it dough and the oil at this point sure
why not it's quite wet and sticky very
nearly too sticky to work with the dough
should no longer bounce back but you can
see like when I put my fingers into it
it kind of holds its shape which is what
I ultimately wanted to do but I'm gonna
give it a quick little pull test you
ready for this it's still pretty brittle
right here but it definitely feels way
different than any previous batch oh the
dough is getting good
oh yeah
oh yay welcome how's it going
I've seen better days I'm using cake
flour for the first time yeah and I
needed this for like maybe 40 minutes 40
minutes by huh yeah Wow
I just don't have a delicate enough
touch to do it yet I need to correct it
really like delicate touch boom boom
so you think cake fluorides to answer
this dough feels much nicer to work with
in any dough he had previously I feel
like you should have made it a little
longer that's a noodle Rea just leave
that there and then let's work on some
other noodles so much mage I don't know
oh hell yeah baby hey there's one noodle
okay that's not a big deal okay I have
one super fat one here this isn't
working
okay I give up on that okay so that's
pretty much the end of day three and I
think I'm at the part where I need to
really figure out how to pull them
evenly so tomorrow same dough recipe
working on the pulling hopefully we'll
have a bowl of noodles by the end of the
day so I needed it for about 40 to 50
minutes and now when I touch it it don't
bounce back okay ready here we go hmm
that's one thick noodle here's to
thinner noodles I mean that's like more
or less without those breaks that's
basically it that's noodles
that's noodles okay there's a little bit
of noodles right there
if I are good at this you would just be
able to make a portion of noodles out of
one pull but I cannot do it evenly
enough I think it would take years of
practice to get that good so instead I'm
just making like four noodles at a time
we're ready to do the final plating of
these noodles I've got some salted water
boiling my noodles are slumbering under
here
I've got herbs to garnish the bowl with
hello EA how did it go not great but at
least the dough worked I have some
noodles here what I did that with my
hands no not a machine noodles are
cooking beef broth did you see that all
this is handmade Rea don't worry about
the broad if you'd like to see a broad
video we have a comment I'm straining my
noodles look at that that's a ton of
noodles I just made who hide this thick
one I'm not hiding my shame thick noodle
goes back in watch out we a dangerous I
run a tight ship over here in Andrews
noodle world yeah that's looking good
cilantro more cilantro onions some of
these are quite thick and how about for
a splash of color boom a little chili
oil good
that's a bowl noodles you did it sort of
you can see they're very uneven that's
easily the hardest part it's magic what
they do are you happy yes because it's
over yeah really it's very rigid Adam
you want to try some good that's really
tasty yeah yeah chili oil this was the
longest episode yet so little was
accomplished but you know high respect
oh yeah oh that must are very much yeah
this has been eating the hand-pulled
noodles out of my feed oh yes
[Music]